you have become like this mega brand
like at what point am I obviously you
were born to him first but at some point
who decided to beat him Faris how did
you become Tim Ferriss because this is
but when you say Tim Ferriss people know
what that is they're like oh Tim Ferriss
the 4-hour workweek
it's all very annoying like I met you
like five or six years ago nobody knew
who you are you're hanging out with
Kevin Rose and now that's the secret
right there but now you're like this
best-selling author you're a household
name more as much as a lot of the
internet brands here how did you become
actually Tim Tim Ferriss the brand when
you look back on it what was there and
was it intentional I'll answer the last
part first first well actually I should
thank you for inviting me on the show
thank everybody for coming it's it's
really fun to be here and you mentioned
a couple of startups I actually have
quite a bit of background parole as well
yeah so TaskRabbit about part of that
entire sort of combination and to answer
the last part first it wasn't
intentional in fact they never had any
plans to be a writer at all and when I
graduated from school I don't know why
my voice is cracking like Doogie Howser
will fix that and post but I promised
myself that I would never write anything
longer than an email ever again because
my thesis just about killed me clearly
that plan did not pan out for me but I
feel very certain at least in my life
whenever I have a concrete five or ten
year plan for that to be reliable you
have to aim well below your capacity and
you cut off a lot of options so it's
really been sort of a six to 12-month
serendipity but the before our work week
really opened the doors for me open all
the doors and that book I think took
hold in part because it was one of the
first books that focused on single
author blogs primarily and blogs at
large as a way of launching and it's not
because I had some amazing insight that
nobody else had in part is because my
publisher would only let me touch stuff
on
the internet wanted to control
everything else you know after being
turned down 27 times 29 I forget you got
to turn down 20 at least in time it was
a 4-hour workweek at least 27 it might
have been more than that what was the
inspiration though for that book and for
the I mean would you consider it like
life hacking was something you were
obsessed with well I did wasn't really
ever unemployment well I didn't think of
it as life hacking and I think you know
hacking as useful as the term can be is
kind of overused to the point of being
somewhat meaningless these days but I
always wanted to be a teacher never
wanted to be a writer I always thought I
would come back and teach maybe 9th or
10th grade at some point because I had
inflection points in those years that I
can attribute to very specific teachers
and if I'd gone the other direction like
a lot of my classmates who are now dead
because they OD it or whatever I I
wanted to be in a position to make that
kind of difference but I never thought I
would write as a way of teaching the
book was put together really as a
collection of notes as I went about
trying to repair my own life and
reinvent my my life and career and what
was so broken in your life that you
needed to fix it I well the wake-up call
was in 2004 or so and a long-term
girlfriend broke up with me and gave me
a sort of parting plaque that said
business hours end at 5 p.m. and I still
have this thing it has a collage of like
my head is cut out as a photo it's on
this sort of like paper body with the
business suit running with a briefcase
and papers flying out of it and she was
like keep this for your own personal
well-being goodbye and I was caught
dumped I got dumped hard and I was on a
walk he caught me completely unaware
which is ridiculous because I was
working from whatever was you know
seminary in the morning to like 9 p.m.
cest chasing timezones
I I never had more financial success at
that point and I probably never been
more unhappy either so that was I think
the the wake-up call for me doing at
that time that was a sports nutrition
like supplement company that I built up
after obsessing over that stuff and self
experimenting for
years and years since sort of legal and
illicit and everything in between
substances and did you find a favorite
which category let's see yeah sure we're
a friend who's not someone what is the
term swish someone who is not me swim
messageboards they put like someone who
is not me oh of course then they talk
about like the emotion chasing which by
default means for for bait I would say I
I feel like people either swing both on
the performance well on the recreational
side certainly people tend to swing
towards stimulants or depressants and
people are pretty easily split in either
direction I've never been a depressant
guy and I had athletes introduced me to
ephedrine caffeine and aspirin the ECA
stack which I which is extremely
addictive and it's that was my
superformance drug of choice it's highly
addictive and it took me more than a
decade to get off of it so I highly
discourage the exactly you take an
aspirin you combine ephedrine caffeine
and ephedrine caffeine and aspirin in a
particular ratio that basically gives
you a synergistic in the most literal
sense effect whereby York instead of
combining 1 plus 1 plus 1 to equal like
20 biochemically and it's it's very
strong on the illicit side and I still
don't know if I'd call this recreational
but I'm a big fan of psilocybin
mushrooms I think they're very
underutilized for therapeutic purposes
yeah yeah and by the way all the tea
you've been drinking we we took the
liberty of putting mushrooms in them
yeah yeah gonna be a great second half
about five of you got ayahuasca so we'll
know who you are pretty quickly yeah
that'll be the naked running up
so what is it but but the branding the
branding stuff I've never really
directly thought about building a
personal brand and that may be
surprising for some people to hear but
I've thought about diversifying my
identity at different points so there's
a point where I realized that didn't
want to be the 4-hour workweek guy
forever and made the deliberate choice
to run the risk of not doing 4-hour
workweek to you know the three hour
workweek and selling it for a fortune to
a publisher that could have done and
doing the 4-hour body very very
deliberately so that I would have sort
of two worlds to sit in if the 4-hour
body were successful and then there came
a point where I said you know what I
don't want to be the how to author
indefinitely
why don't I diversify my identity with
angel invest and we started in 2007 and
so I've made those choices along the
lines so that my self-worth and
perception of myself is not tied up in
one basket much like an investment
portfolio I don't want to run the risk
of being becoming depressed if one area
of my life collapses